so I recently completed a review of re0
was uploaded and haha was it a literal
minefield of comments and opinions I
have not had a comment section this
heated since I've done a video sword art
online which is always guaranteed to set
up a bombshell on one side yet the usual
group of hype anime haters finding it
difficult to even fathom how such a show
got so popular on the other side were
the die-hard fans who deflected any
criticism thrown against it and
somewhere lost in the middle were the
people who are just like yeah it was
right but the one thing I constantly
noticed on the side that were defending
re0 was the continuous reference to the
source material to counter any criticism
that was made this guy dismisses the
point of the larger story every problem
we had gets answered in arc for anyway
are you an absolute idiot gigger you're
criticizing the narrative when it's just
the prologue the prologue which after
hearing well that's I could only think
one thing here we [ __ ] go again
see ignoring the fact that a prologue
that last 25 episodes already has flaws
in its narrative structure as longer
stories has been able to set up a
narrative in the much shorter time and
that longer prologue that have existed
before like berserk are essentially
self-contained stories with their own
narrative and that there is absolutely
no indication at all that this is just
the prologue please don't make this an
argument about where the Reiser is a
good prologue or not I did like the show
guys I'm just trying to make a larger
point here the bigger issue here is that
people are using the source material to
excuse the criticisms of an adaptation
and honestly this isn't the first time
this has happened and by god won't it be
the last either we see this a lot with
adaptations that have yet to be complete
or source material that is just really
hard to adapt like oh you guessed it the
faith franchise the granddaddy of this
entire debate see whenever I've seen
someone criticize either one of the Fate
adaptations it's almost guaranteed to
trigger a plethora of fans of the visual
novels it was based on either we were
watching it wrong or the criticisms we
had were never really true because they
were addressed in the visual novels and
we should have really read the visual
novel before watching the anime because
that's the only real way to prop the
experience tips and while fate is
definitely the easiest example I can
think of this way of thinking is
scattered across many different anime
franchises the peculiar thing is that
anime is any place I've really seen a
source material brought up as an actual
defense of the
patience as I definitely don't see this
as much in other mediums for example we
don't see the Watchmen comics used to
cover up any faults as movie had or any
other film adaptations for that matter
help we don't even see anime used as an
excuse for bad anime adaptations because
that's exactly how they're seen just a
bad adaptation outside of anime sees
more widely acknowledged that an
adaptation is separate from the source
material and it's judged independently
we see the words based on and we
immediately accept that whether this be
a good adaptation or bad adaptation it
should be judged based on its own merits
and that's the way it should be every
medium has different strengths and
weaknesses and you'd be dumb to think
that a complete one-on-one adaptation
would work for every story in every
medium what's important in my opinion is
that the adaptation contains the essence
of the source material Lord of the Rings
is a great example of this as for the
critical and commercial success that it
was
huge chunks of the original books were
cut out honestly leaving the films as an
incomplete picture of Tolkien's entire
universe yet it didn't matter because it
was a standalone piece in a medium that
yours in regardless of what it was based
on for this to happen the source
material must be viewed as a completely
separate piece of work
in other words irrelevant this is not to
say that we ignore the existence of the
source material at all but when judging
an adaptation it is important that we
look at both pieces of work individually
and not as a whole so why does it seem
like anime is treated differently to
other mediums
well anime is also a unique medium in
the sense as it's more used to seeing
one-for-one adaptations since with the
history of anime production which is
adapting manga stories the manga it was
based on is almost used as complete
storyboard an anime has evolved over the
years with this principle because of
this the majority of modern anime don't
even adapt the source material all the
way to the end due to the anime
production cycle these days unlike with
American TV shows which normally get
some kind of ending when the network
cuts it off or movies which only really
adapts things that are already complete
the amount of anime which only gets one
or two seasons with open endings never
to be seen again
is vast we're forced to judge the
adaptations we have because well we have
no guarantee that we'll ever see more of
it but this does beg the question of
whether these kinds of adaptation are
truly standalone or more of a
complementary piece of the source
material and extension of the original
body of work see
as I mentioned before with movies and
their source material being judged
entirely independently a lot of the
times anime adaptations can just be a
part of a bigger whole as I mentioned
with face they night and 80-plus our
visual novel with multiple routes and a
nonlinear narrative it is very difficult
my own impossible to create a faithful
adaptation where you get the same
experience as you do reading the visual
novels the same can be said with
incomplete adaptations like three zero
so far vote to a less complicated extent
so with all this in mind should we think
of anime is just an extension of the
original body of work no for me to think
that would be to undersell anime as a
medium and their subsequent adaptations
there is so much more to judge when it
comes to an anime adaptation you have
animation art voice acting music
cinematography and so many more elements
that blend into a product that warrants
it to be judged by its own merits we
have good adaptations and bad
adaptations and even if we don't get the
complete story it's still the animes job
to give you some sense of closure at the
end of the season even if it's not the
true ending this is why anything like
the original berserk anime are so
detested because they left us right in
the middle of a [ __ ] arc
this doesn't even take into account
anime original endings because like them
or not they are their own separate thing
and have been shown that they can work
you know at least once going back to the
Lord of the Rings example you don't need
a complete adaptation for it to work you
just need an adaptation that works and
the medium is being presented on and
it's not the source materials job to
cover up any faulty adaptation has is
the adaptations job to make sure it
works in the first place for example if
this season of re0 is just the prologue
where is the indication in the
adaptation that this indeed is just the
prologue plus if we can properly judge
something until the entire story is over
that would mean that like 90% of anime
would-be unreviewable I mean how can we
probably judge unless it's complete yet
guys there's still like 400 volumes of
manga left to adapt you wouldn't
possibly know if it's good until you've
seen absolutely all of it in the end
what this really is about is fans
wanting others to share their experience
they had with a certain franchise and
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that I've been on both sides of the
fence with this one both as an anime
only watch of watching a so-called awful
adaptation and the fan trying to defend
a franchise because an adaptation did
not live to what I wanted it to be
inevitably we will always be more
fected with the medium we first
experienced asourian and when someone
can't see the entire picture of what you
experience because of a shoddy or
incomplete adaptation we feel the need
to defend the experience we had so can
we all just for a moment take a step
back and see that adaptations are not
the source material
different adaptations can have different
experiences that are judged entirely
independently so someone criticizes the
adaptation they are criticizing your
experience or the thing as a whole it's
just simply what they saw or maybe they
just have a shitty opinion like me
[Music]